foreign
can you define anxiety is it possible to
cure it or is it something that is just
a part of life
you know the experience of anxiety is
literally wired into our nervous system
which is always sensing the environment
around us outside of our awareness
through a process called neuroception
which is simply means we're always on
alert for that possible threaded hand
now again back in childhood if we were
under support it when we were
dysregulated when we were upset when we
were stressed when we were having a need
as a child if we didn't have a caregiver
to come and help regulate our nervous
system that's actually what's happening
when an infant is crying as a state of
dysregulation and without that attuned
caregiver we are in such a state of
dependency that our nervous system can't
regulate itself much like we can't meet
our own needs so the more consistently
then that happens what a lot of us
become wired then into is a state of
dysregulation we never come back from
that point of stress back to that point
of safety because again in childhood we
can't do it physically physiologically
on our own and the very many of us we
didn't have that level of Attunement so
what we then experienced much like I
described myself the little girl afraid
of the world I mean I've had an anxiety
disorder diagnosis for as long as I can
remember and I have all the letters OCD
Gad you know panic disorder that's
generalized anxiety disorder so in terms
of can we heal it for a very long time
seeing similar patterns in my family
coming from a very anxious family I
imagined as many of us have been told
that it's genetic that I have no ability
to create change around this and it
really took me exploring and learning
about the nervous system and this very
natural system to come to the awareness
that what my body was actually stuck in
was a nervous system state of of
response I felt so again overwhelmed all
of the time that the anxiety that I was
experiencing near constant was that
marker all of the time telling me that
everything again is threatening outside
of my awareness so even in moments where
I shouldn't seemingly be anxious and I'm
on the brink of a near panic attack it
didn't mean that I'm inevitably going to
be an anxious individual what I really
learned was that was my body just
continuing to send out those messages
that it is just simply not safe so the
biggest transformation happened when I
hey learned all of this and then B began
to apply in terms of my own healing
Journey so a lot of us have the
generalized anxiety the panic disorder
the social anxiety which is a form even
of that people pleasing I'm so hyper
Vigilant to the world around me and so
concerned with how I'm being perceived
I'm always on edge when I'm particularly
around other people and again I could
make a case at one of the underlying
causes for this or contributors to that
experience is actually in our body in
that dysregulation which actually can be
healed with these constant choices like
we were talking about earlier caring for
my body learning how to regulate it in
the moment so to answer the question
more specifically in terms of can it be
healed I mean as far as I'm concerned I
would not resonate or relate to being
being an anxious individual do I have
moments where you know I have that
marker of oh I'm fearful you know
something's you know telling me that I'm
feeling you know something that is akin
to anxiety but I would not describe
myself as being anxiety as I once did
man I have to run by myself on a regular
basis my parents aren't in control
anymore and I realized like that's one
large piece of my anxiety I always feel
like the rug is gonna get swept off
underneath me like when everything is
going good I'm like well
everything's going great but something
bad's gonna happen because that's how
it's always been because that's how it
was when I was a kid like I mean anytime
I felt like life was going great
um I don't know man mom gets a DUI uh I
don't know step dad beats me I mean it
was like always like something that was
interrupting this happiness so I was
programmed to feel anxious anytime I'm
happy and um yeah I have to remind
myself on a regular basis like hey man
like your parents they don't get to ruin
your life anymore right yeah Matt you
don't want to cure your anxiety your
anxiety is an alarm clock and if I could
give you a pill so that you slept
through your alarm clock that wouldn't
do you any good you would simply be
sleeping through the alarm that tells
you you need to do something anxiety is
simply telling you hey there's something
wrong here now specifically you're gonna
have to figure out what that wrongness
is I don't mean morally wrong but if
your house is super cluttered yes that's
going to cause anxiety in your life if
you're super unhealthy yes that's going
to cause anxiety in your life if you
have a ton of debt anxiety is going to
appear if you have toxic friends toxic
family toxic relationships you're going
to see anxiety permeate your life and so
we have all of these warnings that's
what anxiety is you don't want to cure
the anxiety you want to witness it now I
do have four things that have really
helped me as soon as I know that oh this
is pointing me toward a problem if I
want to calm down the anxiety I tend to
change my state and there are four
things that I do regularly the first
thing is a breathing exercise something
like the Wim Hof method it's just 30
deep breaths
and it's almost like you're
hyperventilating it's up you're not
you're not breathing out as heavily
right a YouTube video with him we'll put
a link to that in the show notes but
I'll do a Wim Hall Health breathing for
just a minute or two minutes it's 30
breaths and all of a sudden I feel my
nervous system
self-regulate another thing I'll do is
I'll get in some sort of cold water so
it could be a cold River Cold Lake a
cold plunge an ice bath at home or just
a simple cold shower for two minutes two
minutes is all you need completely
changes your nervous system for the rest
of the day there's a lot of science
behind this another thing that I will do
is I will just Sprint up a hill if I can
somewhere nearby just go run feel that
physiology change as I'm sprinting to
the yeah as fast as I can possibly
Sprint and it feels great all of a
sudden the anxiety goes down but of
course it comes back if what if I don't
address the problem that caused anxiety
in the first place and the fourth thing
I do is hug
if I just hug someone before I prolong
extended awkward period of time I'll
even say hey I really need a hug right
now or give me a hug it also changes my
nervous system now partially it's
because I'm stealing electrons from
whoever I'm hugging but also it calms me
down so those four things are how I
alleviate my own anxiety did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free